good morning good afternoon good evening
depending on where you are joining us
from welcome to simply learn or honored
to have you join us today for
data-driven digital marketing with your
host Nick battle-ax my name is Richard
and after the center will be mostly in
the back ground helping Nick so that
everything goes smoothly and then I'll
come back in for the last 15 minutes to
help with the question and answers
data-driven digital marketing and the
DMC digital marketing certification in
2015 more data was collected than all
the previous years put together knowing
how to use all this data now available
for businesses or companies is mote in
most industries is a necessity to keep
up with the competition in the marketing
out there if you do not know Nick Nick
is a digital marketing all things online
marketing expert with 18 + years
experience regional trainer at Google
lead trainer simply learn marketing
motive digital vidya and godaddy as an
entrepreneur himself Nick helps
businesses of all sizes to grow and
reach their target clients he comes with
with a bachelor's from hopes masters in
business but I was going to down rate
him there a masters in business
administration from humbler business
school he also has University of Toronto
digital marketing and he's certified in
just about everything digital marketing
I can't go through the whole list
because that would be the whole hour if
you're not familiar with this form of
webinar I want to introduce you to your
dashboard if you everyone can locate
your dashboard and control panel might
have to click on the red arrow to expand
it go ahead and find the question module
and if you can just open the question
module and say hi to Nick lets us know
you're excited to be here and this also
lets just know you're hearing us okay
and that our sound system is working so
just go ahead and type in hello there
this question module is your best friend
this is a great place to ask any
questions for your own personal journey
hello Joseph and great to have you here
your own personal journey and also if
you have a company question or
certificate
asian question this is a great place to
go ahead answer to ask those questions
in the last 15 minutes at that point
we'll go ahead and try to address as
many of these questions as we can and
great to have you Kimberly Connor yogesh
got a nice crowd in here today you
didn't come here to listen to me I am
proud to introduce Nick who will be your
host for data-driven digital marketing
go ahead and sit back relax have a cup
of coffee or tea maybe it's evening
where you're at and maybe a glass of
wine and a joy and enjoy it's an honor
for me to end this over to Nick thank
you and happy learning hello Nick and
welcome to simply learns webinar today
oops now you're it oh there we go
sometimes those make foot buttons you
have to click on them or they kind of
hide thank you very much for being here
today Nick and works i'm excited to have
you here and listen to the talk i'm
going to go ahead and meet myself and
let you take over there all right so
that i'm excited to say merry thank you
so much for giving me the axis hope
everybody is able to hear me loud and
tear and can also see my screen i'm just
going to go ahead and present across the
topic for today which is data driven
dates to the marketing thank you so much
for a lovely introduction i'm authorized
and honored so my name is nick i'm just
going to take few minutes throughout a
few seconds to go ahead and just you
know give you a rush through
introduction from my side also that's
already look like imma did still mafia
enthusiasts have been into this
profession for 18 years and i'm going to
the both side of the industrial digital
marketing which is the servicing side
and also from the training end so when I
say servicing arena it's I have got my
own agency by the name of your brain
that's based out of canada toronto and
in terms of certifications if we talk
about I've made myself eligible for all
the possible and certifications in
digital marketing industry and like
Richard i mentioned i am masters in
business administration from university
of toronto and i have a full-time role
to take care of with my agency internet
marketing agency
which is by the name of your creations
you have to be based out of Toronto
Canada I'm also speaker at various
business schools and colleges based in
Canada and India boat some of those big
University of Toronto same place from
where I passed out hamburgers raanta and
I am bangaru I am ambivalent wear blue
many others in case you want to know
more about me in detail you can just go
to linkedin.com type in across my name
you will find my profile pretty easily I
do provide training at several places
some of those become up with photo daddy
for Google Microsoft and others they're
talking about data-driven digital
marketing many people say that you know
the data which we have God as a digital
marketers I'm assuming everybody over
here has got something or the other to
do with its full market keeping that in
mind the way first slide what I'm
talking about over here is what data can
really help why I've got this first team
this thing is the first slide is just
because that's the way that's the
maximum number of people actually asked
me or you know when they talk about they
determine digital marketing now we as
marketers we have digital marketers we
know that there's a tremendous amount of
data which we do get on regular basis on
constant basis and this data is the
after effect is the result of all the
campaigns we run across when I say the
campaign's would could be of any kind
any kind of a digital marketing campaign
whether it's an email marketing campaign
or a google search campaign or display
campaign then across an a sort of an ad
network or whether it's a old media
campaign which is where your web site
comes up onto the top if the organic
listings are people are talking about
your brand it's a word of mouth
advertising on the social platform so
people are talking about your brand
you're getting shares your content is
getting wild all you really get across a
huge amount of data now we do talk about
how this data is to be used across the
data which we get across from the
analytics whether it's Google and things
or any other analytics platform it
so kiss matrix are Omniture these are
pretty a renowned analytics platform if
you get across a lot of data from the
Pinterest analytics from facebook
Insights our visa if you talk about
let's say google webmaster which is all
very popularly known as google search
console now where we get a lot of
information from google and how our
website is for home and so forth when we
encapsulate all that data you're not
really sure how to really take decision
in the right way that's what they did it
data-driven digital marketing is all
about when digital marketing started I
would say you know 94 is in the air when
it already got started it was a very
initial stage there wasn't a lot of data
which was involved it wasn't there
wasn't a lot of number crunching which
was to be back across so as things move
further there was a lot of Internet
users the number of people who were
using across internet that really went
up and there was a rapid expansion
expansion on that a lot of data God
accumulated by marketers they were
really not sure on how to use that data
for the best hospitals so if me if I
have to really sum up how this entire
piece of data i'm not going to show you
the entire day i'm assuming that all of
your somewhere or the other links to
digital marketing and in the analytics
platform in the unlit stash board and
all that you do with a lot of data how
does that they really help so if we talk
about a well-oiled data-driven digital
marketing operation they'll help to
identify the most valuable segments and
the harden leads for each now if i talk
about segments we do have the ability to
go ahead and dissect across the entire
database into whatever segments I want
giving you an example of a segment is
like let's suppose if I get 1,000
visitors in a day on to my website how
many of those are spending 22 minutes or
more than that i can just segment across
my visitor database not up into a
certain section
which will show me only that set of
people on a bad set of data on that set
of visitors precisely who have been on
to my website for two minutes or more
than that that's up to me how do i
define that now this segmentation are
various find some our default segments
which are there to the analytics some
are custom-made segments which we can
create not just on the base of time
which people are spending on to our
website they could be further more
segments which are possible like things
like how many people were browsing on to
my website using a mobile phone or how
many people were browsing on to my
website let's say yesterday or even
right now on real-time basis using a
specific tablet that's all possible now
when you get all that data we are able
to identify and understand more about
our audience and the kind of audience
which have converted the most this is
also possible this is also the data
thing the conversion data is also very
essential to be looked at the entire
piece of data which is providing us
information about all those people who
have got converted or all those our
visitors who came onto our side and sort
of left their details now filled up the
form or what across the product whatever
we wanted them to do that sort of entire
piece needs to be looked into carefully
I need to understand where have they
come from almost time to disband what
place what page did they visited the
most and so forth so this is one example
we have to really see in terms of the
hotel needs what what people have been
doing what have been the common things
amongst those people who have bought
product from our website or who have
been really a a good prospect for us it
also heads us a you know a perfect oiled
data-driven digital marketing operation
would help us to be very much relevant
to our customers with personalized
messages if I talk about this point
number two the I would really like to
bring across the two everyone's notice
that whatever in
champions you get on day-to-day basis
they all are most of them are first
lives how how do these advertisers
really get to know that uh you know this
is what your tastes and preferences are
now that's an example of an email Cap'n
even if I talk about a display banner ad
you must have observed that whatever
third party website whatever piece of a
website you go the banner ads that you
get to see over there they were very
much related to whatever interests you
have whatever websites you have been
buying you have been browsing across or
whatever things you really want to buy
across so that's so much personalized
even they go ahead and talk about the
messaging within the emailers and
messages within the display which help
which gets run across with the help of
the data and also the cookie system
which is also called a retargeting and
remarketing which most of you are aware
of that's also an after fact that's also
one of the greatest form of campaigning
advertising which gets done only with
the help of data what is that data that
really lets believe targeting and
remarking here or works it's a cookie
cookie is a small file which cannot be
seen by a visitor to a website and this
cookie helps in else the advertiser to
go ahead and showcase their ad what has
been to all those people who have been
to their website before and the reason
of showcasing the banner ad only to that
set of people who are being to your
website before but haven't got really
converted it's just because they are
known to your brand they know that this
grand exists and they've got that they
have seen that they've seen their butts
they've seen your website and be into
your website you just want to convince
them more you just want to convince and
also remind them right that's where
retargeting really helps and then that's
one of the greatest form of data-driven
digital marketing I'm not a date for
data-driven it's remarketing is a
programmatic buying now that's a piece
of the business advertising purely
I'm going to talk touch base a bit on
the programmatic buying programmatic
advertising all together where every
single impression on the publishers
website is getting sold across on the
basis of what the demand of the
advertiser is it's not just a spray and
pray thing which in traditional market
is really good if you talk about the
display advertising which people were
bitching marketers happy doing so far it
was just all about spray and pray in the
beginning and then it went on to
targeting furthermore with the help of
psychographics and demographics but with
programmatic advertising if you talk
about you're not just focusing on
showcasing our banner ad to a bunch of
people but we are able to pinpoint every
single audience the way we want to on
the basis of what they have been seeing
what sort of websites that have been
seen lately what kind of browsing
history do they depict their interest
level and so forth so every single
impression which is getting so depressed
that's also an aftereffect it's also an
overall result of potato Haven digital
marketing so the data is getting used
for the retargeting for remarketing for
the programmatic advertisement so forth
also the data helps in in better
performing campaigns at a lower cost so
there have been several studies have
been several experiments you know in
life campaigns which have run across it
does show a campaign ran across with a
lot of calculation a lot of you know
carefully the data has been used across
for that sort of a campaign where the
data has been used the cost has been
considerably very low as compared to
that sort of a campaign where there
hasn't been any use of data or maybe a
negligible use of data and so forth so
usage of data has always helped the
advertisers in reaching out of the right
set of audience and the right place in a
much lower cost as our versus the other
form
of digital marketing campaigns also the
traditional campaigns so this I mean
there's comparison in the traditional
phone digital marketing at the new form
of digital marketing where data has been
used to cosmos also the data-driven
digital marketing operation helps us in
analyzing data to find more new
opportunities where can we really go
ahead and show across our product our
entire advertising message so that's
another thing also the other benefit is
that it helps in increasing the value of
the customer database so now this entire
operation if I talk about the data
driven digital marketing operation that
really works well when it's been linked
to a great either a marketing automation
tool and also customer relationship
management tool where every single
customers profile is being stored and
what sort of activities every single
customer has performed on to your
website what happened their past
purchases their past behavior that all
gets recorded and on the base of all
that which gets recorded into the
customer database and and it gets
chilled well with your campaign for wild
as our campaign tools you are able to
not just personalize the messages but
you are also able to send them at the
right spot in with the right sort of
entire messaging being very fine-tuned
for every single set of audience so we
can talk more about the automation
Cardinals the customer relationship
management how that really gets into
this and makes the entire process more
smoother and much more valuable another
thing which data would really helps us
helps the marketers is to get marketing
sales and the entire IT department of a
single organization on the same page
that's what they really tells know this
is the biggest challenge with many
agencies have been facing that is always
a miscommunication or some son of a
up in the understanding of these two
three different departments the
marketing the sales and the IT you know
to get them onto the same page it some
numbers it's a data which really helps
them to give them on the same page and
have a clear unified understanding of
what needs to be achieved what is the
overall you know activities which would
be performed across and what could be
the after effects expected out of those
activities which would be perform and
the last one is to benefit if you talk
about how to put help data is to
introduce efficiency with automations
which I said to scale without paying so
automation platforms like if you talk so
I would very much want to hot spot
market or children automation platforms
that helps an entire you're getting the
data driven into marketing campaigns
walk across Oh Frankie right so now if
you talk about the automation part which
with the last pointer marketing
automation is absolutely in rage these
days and for all good reasons and the
air are some examples of what can be
achieved with the right customer data
value so automated email campaigns is
what the marketing automation platforms
helps in in order to push prospects for
different stages of the purchase cycle
right from the top of the funnel where
the prospect I mean is trying to know
about various plants if he or she is in
the awareness stage and then jumps on
from the awareness stage to be a
decision-making stage the evaluation
stage and then do the purchase stage and
then for the purchase to the post
pertains after sales and so forth also
it offers you know the offers and so
forth are being triggered by specific
user data or the actions if somebody
comes onto your website and performs
across a successive a specific action
then only an email is being triggered
across that's the beauty of the
automation that really helps and it
Jen's well again with the data so
somebody comes on your website i'm
giving an example
bias across let's say a pair of red
shoes automatically uh you know let's
say the purchase has been done
automatically an email will get sugar
across maybe let's say after a day
whatever rule is being set across which
and the email says I'm sorry the email
says you recently bought a pair of red
shoes outward buying the cross this pair
of denims which would call relevant with
issues I mean that's the beauty of
automation also if you if there are more
stats the more data about that specific
about all the customers I'm sorry about
that just give me a second right so this
can be personalized more in terms of the
information of the customers whatever
they are purchased more to that specific
let's say red shoes I'm sorry about that
now the other benefit of automation
which brings in the data-driven digital
marketing campaign to perform a cross
for the best without it helps in lead
scoring as well the automation tools
else in segregating the leads whether
it's a level 1 or level 2 but it's more
hot hot lead right now it's in the cold
stage I mean it would take a lot of time
so the entire pipeline gets visible and
one can really anticipate and predict
for future how many sales could they
really expect in the upcoming months and
so forth also helps in the retention in
nurturing the existing customers by
sending them much more valuable stuff
useful content or useful offers and
deals on regular basis now again this is
a part of the data driven digital
marketing whatever emails you get on
regular basis from various different
websites they do talk about loyalty
bonus the benefits of
being part of their top are the benefit
of buying across from their store or
from their outlet again and again so
just to in order to get much more higher
lifetime value from every single
customer it's the role of automation
which along with the data that really
comes into test now this has been
explained diagrammatically in this
particular slide how the automation
really works across so you got dumbo at
number one place you got the customers
the customers do with it across your
website various different channels for
this of the social or any let's say me
so Chad or maybe additionally ad or an
email and so forth the moment they come
onto your website from various sources
they sign up to receive exclusive
content they have given macross
permission to you by putting across
their name number so there's always
going to be a filtration process and the
system entirely tracks right so there's
a lot of data which is first of all
getting fooled getting collected at a
very first stage that all people came
onto your website from what place how
did they reacted and out of how many of
the total people who came on a web said
how many really jumped into Android
across their details and so forth or
maybe did the action which we were
really looking for as a marketer now
this entire piece of information again
out of step 2 and step 3 gets captured
across no and that gets pulled across
that gets stored across in the
automation platform at step 4 so this
rich data that is being captured across
for the marketing automation platform
that's where the data-driven digital
marketing is happening right this entire
piece of data has been leveraged and it
is use the cost for increasing
engagement for sending personalized
messages at a timely fashion on alerts
are being set up a person in such a
fashion that much more customers are
there to give you more sale
more revenue more profits and also the
existing customers to keep coming back
and stay be loyal with your brand and so
forth and all those who haven't really
got converted again the automation tool
makes it a point that many more
campaigns are being set up across by the
marketers with again for automation to
include just target across the other set
of audiences who haven't really been
converted but they might convert if you
push push for the world could convince
them furthermore now that's a nutshell
guys in totality what the data-driven
digital marketing is all about where the
CRM and also the automation part is
working in together the data is getting
crunched the data is getting used by VCR
and performed by the automation
platforms in together to get across the
ultimate marketing objectives being met
right now now this is more of a complex
uh you know entire chart do not get
scared by looking into this I'm just
going to be quick on to this one the
previous one was pretty simple to
understand if I talk about various
different more people and born into this
entire process what happens is that
whenever you've got audience on to your
website right they do many more things
so people will come on their website to
do either they're searching for some
content is sharing your website on the
social media website doing comparisons
of products and so far on that sort of
data point so these are data points
different data points they are multiple
browsing behavior data points right
there have been captured from various
different sources then all gets
aggregated and it gets stored
disaggregate data gets stored into a
platform that's what DMP that's data
management platform now this is a sort
of a server where the tan theta is
getting stored this entire data gets
analyzed and on the basis of various
different traits which are being already
created in the data management platform
this data it's
being segregated into various different
sections so a different set of audiences
pool you know an audience food which is
let's say a pool one and pull through in
a point three or four for now all those
people who are in the pool one they've
got something in common so let's say
there's a trait which is common amongst
the pool one so you call it as a trade 1
32 33 trade for all of these people
whenever they visit across your website
there loop they're just going ahead and
a get downloading across cookies which
were there on the website they do not
get to know that all these cookies
sleeping they've been classified in two
ways different segments and on the base
of that this now again this becomes your
property as your website are you do get
information certain set of information
about your audience not their names and
email addresses but there in 10 their
interest levels what they were really
looking for and so forth on the basis of
this be there is another platform it's
called demand-side platforms to the
ESPYs they're the ones who will really
do a lot of effort for the advertisers
and on the bases are and they're
connected with the ad servers on the
book on on the basis of the ad servers
there is a lot of real-time bidding
which works across when I say real-time
bidding so there is a bidding for every
single impression which is there now
this works prior primarily for the
display campaigns now this ability
majorly display for the video campaigns
and support campaigns on the mobile apps
and so forth the banner ads and support
the real-time bidding inventory is being
used across to run campaigns are going
against what if I saw the audience will
be looking at the dance the entire
process this is bit more complex if
you've got it good if you haven't really
you can read further more about it by
just checking on a Google and so bored
what do you really understand by BNP and
the DSPs and the ad servers and Alex
teens and so forth and real-time bidding
this is going to give you a quick
overview of what programmatic buying is
where the real time bidding for walks
across now
another piece of example which I would
like to give for data-driven ma
marketing guys except for the inner
personalized messages through
remarketing and retargeting there's
another team which works across are only
for the display that's one look-alike
morning where all these ad exchanges
really provide this functionality it's
also there with facebook if you have
been really quite active on to facebook
advertising facebook do gives an
opportunity to the advertisers to show
their messages their display advertising
messages do I look like audience when I
say look alike audience what the ad
servers or let's say fighting example
again or facebook on your facebook would
do when you as an advertiser have run
across a campaign and you you have
captured a lot of information a lot of
data in terms of who have shown some
interest on to your product who have
really gone ahead and got converted so
the data of those people who are quite
converted they're being analyzed by the
facebook system and when me as
advertiser try to hit another
campaigning in the other campaign we
tried we mentioned that this time you
want to show our ad not do any set of
audience with certain parameters but we
only want to show our ad only those kind
of people who have were very similar to
the kind of audience which have reacted
to our ad participants previously so you
know if i talk about the first campaign
the first campaign we have targeted a
good bunch of people and these two
audiences are converting audience there
the one with red top and a blue top with
blonde hair and black hair and so forth
keeping so let's say you know these are
the traits i mean these are just
physical traits don't go with that if
you talk so over here it's a online
browsing behavior trades or any other
trades which are being matched across
things like let's say profession
things like age and so forth I mean
quite a many things have been looked at
and on the basis of the trains which for
common in the converting audience
similar traits are being searched when
the entire facebook user base and people
who have got similar traits right
similar traits to the ones who have got
to the traits of the one who got
converted earlier they are being pulled
out and the advertisers are very easily
and effectively able to showcase across
their display panel add to this this set
of audiences whenever their live on the
facebook profiles whether it's a right
inside a door a new speed facebook pad
or a facebook even that and so forth
whatever the whatever sort of happen is
when it's there on facebook but it's a
news feed or the right hand side add
only this set of audience is being shown
across now and that is another great
part of data-driven digital marketing
and a lot of organizing so there are a
lot of case studies also which do
showcase at lucca like modeling have
been really over have been really
working well in terms of achieving
better more conversions at a lesser
price so people who like you converting
audience only they're the ones for being
shown for us right i hope it makes a lot
of sense talking about the programmatic
talking about the automation talking
about the real angling and remarking
that's all part of the image now this is
a list of all those attributes and
trades which i was talking about so the
audiences are being segregated on the
basis of any sort of stuff whether
they're microblogging users social media
users financial enthusiasts that's it
travel on travel holid the shopaholic
that taken the technology savvy are
their values seekers are there are they
are these the negotiators are people who
are part in all these different rates
they've been clubbing together the
converting audiences strings are being
pulled out and on the base of that
another set of audiences is being looked
and only those people are polled which I
told you who
similar kids right so now I'm going to
just forgive you glimpse of what
programmatic buying is which is a part
of the entire data-driven digital
marketing is now any sort of an
advertisement which works in an
automated fashion let's say automating
buying and selling of advertising a
display banner ad that's problematic now
involves automating the trigger and
displaying the creative right the ad
banners are the other fonts according to
what the user is looking for asking for
and so forth if we talk for google
adwords to display ads for specific
search pages also that's even program my
god what are the various uses of
programmatic it helps in various
different objectives to be made across
whereas as a marketer you can use it for
brandings purposes for retargeting lead
generation of all this is part of data
and ribbon and it does encompass his a
variety of media so display being the
topmost one like you know the
rectangular had the leaderboard or you
got the square shape once you've got
before the ones on the footer and and so
forth the rich media and so forth the
primary way is to use program adding is
that you can develop creative and wait
for spots to display them or to the
websites right that's a real time
bidding in this real-time bidding
process is the only thing which helps in
helps the advertising and publisher to
meet their objectives in an appropriate
fashion now if I talk about the
objective of an anti Peyser advertiser
is always one look for reaching out to
the right set of prospective audience
were to be very much likely to get
converted at them they're surprised as
less as it's possible on the other side
if we talk about the publishers they
will always be looking for for giving
across space a band a space on their
website do a sort of an advertiser which
matches very well with the content they
have on to the website which matches
very well to be lice and interest on the
audience which comes onto the website
and also pay them a good amount in
so whatever they get for the poor
impression or before puke and so forth
the both parties wants to achieve their
respective objectives and keeping that
in mind it's only the programmatic media
which helps in meeting out this and it's
all of its the entire database crunching
which helps in getting them to so like I
said there can be two things either you
create your own banner ad and then bid
for the spawn spots or you can also
develop which medium is dis fence but
started create variable so now I talked
about the look-alike audience that's
what it is all about in this specific
one so you can have a new screen guard
you can have right inside add you can
target specific people based either
under characteristics with problematic
channels also or you can create custom
audience now one of the custom audience
is the look like audience which other
begin also in programmatic use across
videos so the data-driven digital
marketing is not just restricted to the
banner ads and so forth it's also goes
towards the YouTube advertising the
video analyzed and so forth some of the
beauty mattress and you must have seen
are the pre-roll video ads these are the
video ads which are capable after five
seconds and you always get to see them
before the actual video gets play with
us now how does it happen that if I am
watching a specific video on a YouTube
channel on youtube.com do the video ad
which comes across as very much matching
to what I have been searching for in the
past if I past few days or I am quite
i'm interested in that kind of product
that's all data-driven digital marketing
a lot of data of my characteristics me
as an Internet user is getting pulled
across by those websites which ever i
visit across these websites have the
ability to go ahead and send a cross or
store across certain cookies which goes
from their website the Benham arrive as
an Internet user
their website they're able to download
sir these hidden files it's a corn
cookies into my system into my browser
specific visit is a browser expensively
right so I'm so videos are problematic
to and within the context of the website
also which with websites may visit
that's also possible with video and so
forth not here is an example of a video
ad excuse me a video ad for Microsoft is
getting paid across on folks calm so
Harry specific user was targeted you
don't a specific user you're not just
talking about that this particular
Microsoft ad is going to be visible
across to everybody who would be opening
France volcom know so this is very much
specific through a certain using the
advertiser Microsoft has bid on this
particular stuff that he wanted to reach
out to a certain set of an audience so
when the real-time bidding would have
got done Microsoft would have hidden be
nice then only they were Microsoft was
able to showcase their bit will you add
on forbes.com do a certain set of
audience which they wanted programmatic
assaults there in the mobile and apps so
ads can be automated who's shown on
specific devices such as the mobile
desktop laptop and on an average if you
talk about mobile videos have but 18
person fit through rate which is higher
than laptops and desktop so mobile is
much much more preferable these mobile a
video ads are higher revenue generators
as consumers they do watch most of the
video content on the mobile devices I I
believe you would you would not ah
nobody could ask you on that it's the
mobile mobile devices which are you know
we use the most for browsing internet as
compared to the other devices so it's a
venue is estimated before the mobile if
you talk about to grow three times
faster than the desktop and this town
also costs more bid right so these are
just good to know information and you
can buy ad space on mobile apps as ad
inventory on apps forward additional
routes of 1000 parabola purse
now I'm going to talk about certain
steps for developing a data-driven
digital marketing strategy for an
organization for your organization for
any any sort of an organization so
number one is to implement across first
of all an organization wise wide data
strategies that needs to be there as far
as e in order to be truly bigger driven
data and has to be shared between ways
different business units which I talked
about like two were there with the sales
team with marketing with the IT so that
all of them are on the same page and in
order to be successful data needs to be
managed on regular basis consistently
across all the divisions we're talking
about for this specific reason
businesses do need to ensure that there
is a specific strategic approach to data
that is being adopted on an organization
the number two is to go ahead and
restructure the organization then I say
restructure for data-driven marketing to
become a reality two different business
units the different divisions into your
business and departments they must be
able to collaborate and share the data
it's not just seeing of the data which
is being the loud it's also to go ahead
and collaborate also share more data in
particular silos must be into you know
broken down between IT and the marketing
the data should be broken down an IP is
a vital partner for marketing department
they do play a crucial role in
connecting the Whaley's different touch
points throughout the business and also
supporting the data collection and
overall the integration process so
survey findings they do indicate that
over three quarters of marketers they do
we would need development of a strategic
partnership with IT team answer
privately and then third is to have a
cross-functional team to support the
collaboration amongst the various teams
into also and in the breakdown in
breaking down of the silos organization
should focus if you are working for your
organization for the data-driven digital
marketing campaigns you need to ensure
there is a cross-functional team
including marketers and the IP right
so that's another one and it's all about
integrating the data Samantha's thing do
need to create a single complete
actually being flexible view of their
customers their prospects however most
of the enterprises they do have invested
in numerous marketing technology I mean
we all know that and that they do
specialize in two different disciplines
and so forth so in Restless enterprises
will need to integrate customer data
from disparate systems and so forth
right so it's all about integrating the
data and also then leveraging the
analytics so we all do get across a lot
of data and it through the analytics so
with the data integrated and augmented
businesses they do need to utilize
analytics to deliver actionable insights
and guide the decision-makers it's just
not the marketers that can benefit from
the rigorous exercise it's also ways
different departments ranging from the
sales to the marketing to the coyote
customer service to the finance also for
purchasing and also get much better
profits and so what now gotta you know
infographic being shown over here that
also talks were the same stuff it's a
same thing which I have shown you before
that baileys different into marketing
channels helps in getting us a lot of
traffic where the data comes in and that
data is used across the way this purpose
is also maybe for market research for
customer service department for branding
department for branding purposes or for
targeting customer and so forth right so
we all know that we do get across a lot
of data from Google Analytics webmaster
like I talked about in the beginning
Facebook Insights Pinterest analytics
also from Adwords and so forth so we can
always go ahead and you know this is of
so much time consuming job most of the
organization of God full-time people
working precisely onto the data part in
doing the crunching and taking out you
know uh as much good information as they
can now in the end they I'm just going
to be quick into this there are five
steps for data-driven digital marketing
it
number one is waving as a marketer where
inform across their goals as we all know
it's the SMART goals right a specific
measurable actionable result oriented
and so forth so we will you have the
smartphone's for which is the very first
step it helps you in creating a
data-driven digital marketing campaign
in the most appropriate manner so it
really take a step back and develop
across some goals and objectives for
your strategy right so your goals are
not just going to be for the sales
purpose not the macro you need to have
the micro volts to micro balls would be
like maybe of newsletter subscribers you
want more let's say Facebook Likes you
want more social shares could be
anything then the other thing is to go
ahead and decide across on the key
performance indicators for to which
we're going to act assess your goals
you're going to understand how well you
are doing and measured across your
results as a marketer support instance
of help or implicit amplification might
be cumulative number of shares for a
particular piece of content across
different plant songs and so forth but
you must also identify source of the
data necessary to understand your social
media success where do the KPI numbers
exist in KPI in a single place or do I
need to capture more matrices for
several sources to approximate my que
pienso for number three are the KPI is
to go ahead and collect and display the
data now that you've got the goals
you've got the matrices related to your
KPIs this mean that you're using a third
body tool whether it's Google Analytics
or an O mature or sprout social and so
forth with some more tweaking you might
also use the different API is also [ __ ]
fool antics to you know right across
whatever tool you use you should allow
yourself as a marketer to drill down
onto any metric to get more view more
specifically or the performance for
instance you want to understand not only
where the business really came from but
which platform generated the most
conversions right we spoke about that
and so forth
and number four in the four or five step
process is to go ahead and develop the
insights and developing inside is the
hardest part of the entire managing of
data in a day trader driven digital
marketing campaign this is where the
analysis become a science and not both
and you can use across certain tools for
that you can identify for various
matrices whether it's let's say how much
word of mouth have been happening
whether it's increasing and so forth
looking for correlations between
different matrices and so all right so
that's what I had in terms of the entire
narrative in digital marketing and we do
so rich is going to talk about the DMC
of course we have and so forth I'm just
going to hand it over to Richard
excellent thank you Nick again thank you
for being here today and taking your
time out to join us I appreciate that
I'm going to go ahead and take over the
screen just for a moment here because we
always have a pole well we start our
question-and-answer session and then I
have some great questions coming in here
maybe just a moment there we go hit a
wrong button alright so just as a as a
for my own question as a part of the
startup community an entrepreneur sort
of society in my area I work with
companies community and much more to our
younger crowd who are just coming into
the industry we actually have a whole
group of people are coming right of the
high school or they just started college
in the area what kind of certification
and training advice can you offer to
them as a career choice so that they're
started in the right direction and they
can get going into the digital data
marketing mmm uh I would say by the
basic foundation the dmca absolutely
works the best I mean gives you in a
world overview of what digital marketing
is and what are the different channels
and how do you really get started it's
all I mean when you talk about getting
started with this will marketing yes
dmca course which we have that provides
a complete understanding of birthdays to
market is how do you really start
thinking like a digital marketer whether
you're an entrepreneur or whether you
are you know out of college and so forth
so yeah I am these certifications up we
do provide along with the course that is
the google adwords could be analytics
omcs certifications these are the
initial and most relevant one i would
say yeah okay excellent and would you
does anybody else out there if you do
have questions specific to your business
or your career or what you're working on
or concerning the slides we went through
you know the great time to go ahead and
ask those questions but we have an
expert here you know 18 plus years of
experience that's a lot of expertise
that you can tap into right now for free
on this there is also i'm going to guess
if the answer is kind of the same that
if you are in a business you're going
you're trying to figure out who to hire
and who to work with and you need to
know like a basic understanding so that
when you talk to people you can helps
you pick out the right people and ask
the right questions would it be kind of
the same path getting that basic DMC
certification and getting that started
up there so you know what's going on yes
the answer is going to be the same so
for me feathered yeah what do you want
to do it yourself or you want to get it
down from someone and you want to go
ahead and just judge them let in and
know whether they're taking the right
path they're performing well or not so
the journey needs to start from the same
medium suited yeah okay and then you
said after the DMC the next step would
be like Google Adwords and analytics
what other steps will come after that so
you've gone through and you have a basic
understanding of the data-driven market
and now you're looking at well what do I
go next I go look at Google Adwords and
analytics what other tools
out there that would come next so
they're they're quite many tools well
like we've got a keyboard not only but a
lot of tools for working on to your SEO
campaigns so Google in itself they do
provide a hell lot of tools or analytics
is one of those movie keyword planner is
another one movie AdWords is another
platform which is sort of a tool only i
would say an online tool which needs to
be mastered and that goes hand in hand i
took about the understanding the basic
understanding it's all about mastering
it perfectly and that happens when you
work by yourself onto the tool explore
it spend more time with the tool trying
to see or you know what part is new for
you and when you're exploring it you're
you're trying you just mastering it I
mean why I say you must like it because
there's a lot of the lot of things that
you will understand yourself when once
you're done with the beginners thing you
will have that uh you know you will
start thinking in that direction that
every sort of a new button also let's
say you come across with you you'll have
assumptions around those and once you
put in you know clear on what those
button coupled with your assumptions you
will see whether your assumption was
right or not be how that particular
functionality is gonna work for you but
if you want to really put in shorten up
your pant uh you know after your
beginners course you do not want to go
ahead and keep exploding by yourself and
that would be a bit on Linda fun you can
always vote for our masters you can go
for the Masters force and showing up
your entire part furthermore and learn
much more in a lesser tongue so not
that's something with well is what I
would recommend and that those master
course will help you to get those
certifications excellent and on your
own experience what was like one of the
best projects you worked on where
everything just came together and why do
you think it came together where you saw
a company really excel or an individual
or a business we were able to use the
data analytics and help them build a
company or build a business or build a
section of what they're working on it
was I could recall you know it was for
for an airline brand here uh I don't
want to name them served just because of
some you know agreements and all that so
what what we did with the airline brand
we did a lot of a data const crunching
from the market research point of view
so as a market research we did use quite
a many tools to do a social media
listening we understood what people are
talking about the airline that specific
airline whether it's the good bad ugly
new clue comments it was not a manual
process of going ahead and now you know
extracting these comments on various
social media websites and various so
when two points or blogging sites and
forums and so forth so several tools
were being used to extract those extract
that data then tools were also used to
segregate that and put that piece of
information into the customer
relationship management tool and then
the email campaigns and so forth were
being pushed across the different
segments of these comments of people who
were being commenting about their
experience what they think about the
brand if you know a certain section of
people who've been putting really happy
we used to congratulate them for being
part of our brand and give them across
furthermore promotional offers a section
a segment of you know cus the comp
people were being commenting and
European just neutral I mean it's all
about going ahead and pushing them
further more with certain other
motivations they will have
whether it's again with giving them
price offers are some extra freebies
some taste nurse I mean you don't let
them know that if they go ahead and sign
up with our such-and-such club they can
get across you know maybe this much
price benefit and so for any other hand
you've got another set of audits have
been really vocal about not so great
experience they had and these this was
the audience with which we really had to
control so that the viral effect doesn't
happen the negative the negativity
doesn't really you know gets pushed
across the objective was to tackle that
set of audience in a lesser fraction of
a time maybe if somebody has put in a
cross a negative comment or tweeted
about just let's say a minute back it's
the responsibility of the entire team to
pull out all those on real-time basis
use that data connect with that audience
and so forth so that doubles one history
of my talk about yeah excellent I always
love the stories because sometimes we
get all the information and then we
forget that there's all these steps that
are unique to whatever niche we're
looking at and working with yeah we have
just a couple more minutes I'm always
surprised because usually we have a list
big of a crowd a lot of people have
personal questions that come in so yeah
if you have a question great time to ask
it I'm going to go ahead and close the
poll here in just about a minute and
what was he just kind of going on with
the same theme of personal stories what
was the biggest challenge you ever faced
with digital marketing and working with
a company we're just you know really
kind of hit a wall kind of thing and how
did you deal with that ah the biggest
challenges have been when clients are
not able to you know communicate what
are you looking for so you know how with
my agency when we do get across an
invitation from certain brands saying
that you know we are inviting digital
marketing agencies to pitch in we
in the way for a step ahead and ask them
what are you really looking at so they
go over the place so you know when you
ask them for the requirement they say
everything they say every damn thing so
I we just go ahead and let them know
that you're going to be very specific in
them so what do you want to achieve they
say we need branding on so they said we
need more repeated sales they say we
need more customers new customers so we
tell them that they got to be campaigns
focused on different segments altogether
but it but but clients do not tend to
understand all that many coming up I'm
done I'm talking about just one of a
kind of line who wants every every
different objective of various different
you know kinds do we met with one single
campaign and that's absolutely not
possible so we have to again try to
convince them let them know about
different competitors up there who have
done different sort of campaigns and
every campaign at a specific objective
so we have to really educate our clients
Obree challenge is more with the with
with educating the client I would say
yeah that sounds like a pnp course
communication communication
communication I've certainly heard that
many times and seen that in my own
experience if that is so huge in working
in any small business or large business
we are at the end of the hour again
thank you very much for being here and
greatly enjoyed the talk and myself
learned a lot and I hope everybody else
enjoyed it we're going to go in close
the session if you have any last
comments before we go ahead and close up
then I'm going to go ahead so 10 from
your head yes sorry I guess I didn't get
I get time of communication i forgot to
be more clear on that give me more
anything left Nick that you want to add
before we close the session I'm moving I
believe everybody had a great time and
got value out of the webinar that's all
of our minds except well thank you
everybody for attending we greatly
appreciate for having you here and look
forward to
in our classrooms at simply learn calm
you can also go to the forums if you go
to simply learn calm and click on
community we do have an open forum where
you can ask more questions and of course
we have if you actually join to take one
of our courses and we have additional
forums and personal consultation again
thank you for being here with the poor
to sing in our classrooms everybody take
care and have a wonderful day
you